designed to mitigate for covert
therefore can i ask all the present to
work to the protocols agree to council
on 29th of april this year
in the interest of both member and
officers safe
we are streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and by being present
in the meeting you are giving your
consent to being recorded
um one extra thing i'm going to add in
is because we are streaming uh
it's very important that we only have
one other microphone
at the time trying to be very vigilant
about switching off
uh when you wait for the answer to a
question or whatever
during each item please put your hand up
and
raise your paddle to indicate if you
wish the speed guy will then
invite you at the appropriate time when
invited to speak please remove your mask
on your visor turn on your microphone
and speak clearly
please reference a page or paragraph
number when returning
when referring to the gender papers keep
your contributions
as clear and concise as possible and
ensure your microphones remain off
when not speaking uh just an extra note
to public speakers i'm afraid
because of the numbers we're allowed in
the chamber i am going to have to ask
public speakers to leave when they've
finished the item that they're here for
right can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda papers regarding
different levels in the chamber
advisor the fire exit and indeed the
normal exit when we get to that
is the one behind the top table
all right item two is apologies for
absence
good evening chairman uh we've received
apologies from councillor jarvis
thank you
right next item is declaration no sorry
i apologize
item 3 is the minutes
of the last meeting um
here we go
right i'm going to take these minutes as
read these are the ones from the 16th of
june
does anyone have any matters of accuracy
to raise
okay can i agree this by a cent if
anyone disagrees please let me know
otherwise agree thank you very much
right now it's declarations of interest
i do have to read this bit sorry to
disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests other peculiary interests or
non-communal interests relating to items
of business on the agenda having regard
to paragraph
six to eight inclusive of the code of
conduct for members
and members are reminded they're also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise during the meeting
right council planning thank you chad um
no as
and chairman also not humanly
thank interested right so we move on to
oh sorry so none really interest
relating to
um planning application 21.00104
and
okay thank you sorry i missed you i
wasn't
i didn't notice the hand
right gender item number five this is 21
001
okay
oh you really need help
okay oh
sorry i don't apologize
that's fine thank you
sorry okay um
hello everyone um i'm going to present
this application can you order me okay
um land west of hamburg
and up to a thousand square meters of
flexible commercial
and community space
reserve batteries as well as granted
under 190252 vests
for 75 drillings and it's currently
under construction
the application site relates to the
parcel of the large site
where the thousand square meters of
flexible commercial
and community space was granted consent
this is the site plan showing the site
the
wider site of the 75 dwellings can be
seen
to the north northeast um so north west
and west and you can see the access also
joining foundation uh
this is a more detailed site plan
showing again outlined in red the
uh level site and
with these 75 buildings being shown
in the remaining area in blue and an
area of open space
this is the block plan
see a mixture of housing types
and the access code and there is a road
running
along the western boundary
and southern boundary also
and it will be facing other open space
this shows the housing mix plan
a little bit difficult for me to see but
you can see marked out in red
is four bed dwelling
uh two bedrolling and one bed dwellings
so it offers a housing mix
this is the parking plan
the uh the proposal would comply
with the adopted parking standards for
the district
um at the bottom you can see visitor
parking
and in yellow also
parking that's located close to
development clients
uh landscaping has been indicated
showing a mixture of hard and soft
landscaping as we expected with this
type of development
along with a more concreted road
surrounding the southern northern
western boundaries
so a little bit more detail in terms of
the soft landscaping you can see
that the overall appearance would be
relatively vertical
in particular along the western boundary
again this is a master plan which gives
an indication
of the overall landscaping scheme as it
were
see like two lakes and upper space
to the east of the wider site
and the scheme that's certainly been
built up
to the north west and northwest
now we are moving on to looking at the
detailed elevations of the different
housing types
that are to be provided by the scheme
[Music]
of a four bed market housing
and a prop lens
and another full bed marker glow
associated floor plans
[Music]
these are two bed market dwellings shown
here
what it looks like cream render
um and as you can see
there's also the broadband's also shown
here
this is a two-bed market dwelling
slightly now
than some of the others
we have accommodation above excellencies
on ground pool
and a similar arrangement with this
house also
uh the important thing to point out is
this is a two bed affordable
[Music]
affordable housing has been replaced
with a ski
and some more formal housing also
and another vulnerable unit
and these are some street scenes looking
into the proposed site from
east south west uh as you can see there
is reasonable spacing between the houses
and some of the soft landscaping poses
also indicated
these are details of included with the
circumstances
very standard design
and some of the garages
again that typical residential design
these are some site photos um
you can see my area as well as a good
flat
[Music]
and you can see some of the houses that
have been built
which are would be well our similar
principles being proposed
uh and this scheme of you would
integrate well with that
wider scheme
another another view from
the wider site as seen from fanbridge
road
so in summary um
the principal of a thousand square
meters of commercial community space has
been previously improved
but it's important to point out that the
applicants have marketed this site
for these use footage users and have not
been successful in securing
the commercial community uses
this was done over a three year period
we consider that the marketing exercise
they did
was comprehensive from a significant
duration
and would allow very short-term
fluctuation it's also noted that 4c one
of the development plan
did not direct any form of commercial
development or bandwidth
and although more generally through
windfall developments
therefore there's no evidence at the
time the planting plan could assume that
there was actually need
for these space for this space
so the application would result in the
loss of potential and i emphasize
potential
commercial community use
but there would be a gain of 12
residential units
five of which would be affordable the
application is considered to be within a
reasonably sustainable location
in part due to proximity to the railway
station in north america
and the development 12 residential units
would also
assist in making up the deficit in our
housing land supply
so therefore consider that there are no
objectives and no
objections to the principle of the
development
the design approach is considered to be
appropriate to the site and
result in a seamless addition to the
wider development we have additional
software landscaping proposed
the development provides adequate
off-road parking
meet some energy space standards and
would not result in any materially
harmful
impacts on neighbours residential
nursing
furthermore previous infrastructure
constraints in relation to the site
and final drainage have been addressed
through the installation of a new
rising main to southwestern virus and
this development more connecting to that
network
into this network with condition six
related to this
overall the proposed development is
considered to outweigh
any harm and would represent sustainable
development
as such subject to the approval of s106
agreements secure affordable housing and
the grounds payment
along with the conditions recommended i
recommend this application for approval
thank you thank you right we have a
public speaker on this one
that is the agent uh chris
webber sorry i'm just gonna get it
all right we're just gonna get it
that's it if you can find yourself a
seat please
[Music]
okay right i'll just go through the
rules mr webber please don't start yet
even if you know the rules
and you're getting two minutes precisely
from when uh even though we have a clock
two minutes precisely from when you
start to speak
and i have to warn you i always stop you
even if you're a mid-sentence
sorry about that but it has to be fair
for everyone
okay when you're comfortable please use
your microphone and off you go
all of course well maybe not of course
but please don't
yes that's it
good evening members and thank you chair
for the opportunity to speak this
evening
i'm chris webber planner for david
wilson homes and the applicant for this
proposal
the application proposes 12 new
residential homes on land that was
previously allocated for a thousand
square meters of commercial community
use
under the outline consent from march
2016. a marketing strategy
was agreed with the district council
following which the commercial community
land has been continually marketed since
2017
both online and through print by finding
potential buyer
this marketing strategy has been
comprehensive and for a significant and
extended duration of time
with no viable interest expressed is
therefore the view of both officers and
saddles on marketing agents
that given the small scale of north
america and the lack of passing trade
there is not sufficient demand for
commercial or community uses in the
village
and no reasonable prospect for any such
occupier would be able to sustain a
viable concern
therefore to make the most effective use
of the land an alternative use should be
found
the twelve homes proposed would provide
us alternative more deliverable land use
the homes will assist morgan in meeting
the shortfall of its five-year housing
land supplier
and furthermore the proposal is fully
compliant with 60
of homes being one and two beds
alongside a policy complying 40
affordable housing historically the
provisional disposal of foul drainage
on the site has been an issue of concern
and i'm pleased to confirm that the foul
pumping station
and rising main connection to southwest
waste treatment works
has been completed prior to the first
occupation of the white side
angry water services also confirmed that
the southampton has capacity to accept
flows from these 12 additional homes
meaning foul drainage has been fully
assessed and deemed acceptable
in addition to assist with surface water
flows uh
they wasn't known to carry out extensive
clearances third party water courses
which have been poorly maintained or
blocked
in conclusion there is no demand for the
previously approved commercial such
community use
on the site nor is there likely to be in
the future given the current retail and
commercial markets
conversely these additional homes will
provide a significant planning benefit
and been designed to fit seamlessly into
the white development
okay cool thank you perfect timing well
done
uh right members before we actually go
into the debate does anyone have any
just
questions of fact or dimension or
anything of that nature that might help
everybody out before we
actually enter a debate council planning
thank you jeff
uh i'd like to thank the auditors for
the report and can i just ask
have the developers had a conversation
with you about
reducing the size of the commercial
space
because it's actually ten thousand
square foot
it's actually a lot for that the size of
village
so i just wanted to be clear whether
you'd have discussions about maybe
reducing it down to
2 000 square foot for example separated
into maybe
five units of 600 square foot that could
be used for
i don't know what a convenience store
would be maybe
eight hundred a thousand square foot
i just wanted to know whether those
sorts of discussions had
taken place thank you
discussions about uh
[Music]
is
[Music]
um in the market appraiser report
obviously we've had code since early
2019. so it hasn't really been that in
our report because since
code nobody wants any business space
hopefully we'll return to usual um
the other thing is it seems to be that
there's no public consultation that's
been undertaken about alternative
community uses like a village shop or
any community that's my first one so
are they admitting this was some
residents not written to um
or were just some of them unaware i
don't think the parish council
was consulted by the tender email
um and when we talk about the planning
um
gains against the adverse the npk is all
about thriving communities
but this for me encourages another
dormitory town because there isn't even
a shop there's
nothing in north ambridge so was
discussion
put into this about the viability of the
village um during these discussions
because that um
appears to be it's all about allowing
villages to grow and thrive
and so was this discussed as well and
why was no weight attached to it if it
was
mr chairman um
[Music]
it's a very balanced decision the
recommendation in this instance
um one of the key aspects is that there
was a lack of
advanced need of any type of commercial
enterprise as part of the original
application because it's
very significant to
[Music]
a site being brought forward as you know
i think percentage of council-wise
you want to move forward upside or not
you know as a commercial device
about more favorable smaller bite-sized
piecemeal
um commercial enterprises
there is a valid argument to that point
um it's a balancing exercise
officers consider on balance that take
into account there wasn't any
this is a very much a planning judgment
application and
to essentially these things have been
taken account that's why but it
inside and as members always know it's
within your gift to come to a different
decision for us but you know
you also probably explained all the
issues definitely thank you
so much and everybody else
consulted um with the fact that
um you know this was going to happen it
was just going to be removed its
entirety
um i know a lot of people have said to
me they wanted to shop for something
they said we didn't know they just put
an application to build on it they never
asked us what we wanted
um and that's why i'm curious thank you
mr lee
deejay not to my knowledge
thank you i think council stephen's next
did i see you indicate
no my questions are covered thank you
all right thank you
okay how's your keys down underneath
next good evening
part of my question was covered by
councillor what
it's gotten here keep getting drummed
into me he's gotta be sustainability
right seven point four one
i found a spelling mistake and all i've
only just noticed and that's nothing
not about that it is acknowledged in the
report that the site is in a room
in within a reasonably sustainable
location
with limited facilities and services in
the village
however the rain station which was
supposed to be train station offers good
public
transport links now reasonably
sustainable
location i don't know which has already
come up i don't know
the shop what would
reasonably sustain because i thought it
had to be a shop
or a bus route which it says here only
runs fortnightly the chancellor's on
have we changed the sustainability
bit now so mr taylor
somebody just i keep getting drummed
into as we do it's got to be sustainably
annually okay
yes so in terms of the sustainability in
sight
which is necessarily is drawn from its
connectivity to the railway network uh
there are limited facilities within the
village
buses you're jumping we're trying to get
a point of view sorry
please sorry sorry true
got it sure so you they were expecting
people to jump on the train to go and
get a point of milk to whitford i
suppose you win them
there's one is that yeah yeah
i've got a member that this is part of
the largest site that has been found to
be sustainable except for
housing now that is a material
consideration that
is accepted by an inspector so um it's
not really our place to revisit that as
a principle that
has been accepted already and that's one
of the major issues and
you might consider the is less specific
or maybe bullier but it would be another
before she said but the end of the day
there's planning
history in favor of this and that's a
material situation
this application yes i've got a couple
of people to come to but it does strike
me mr lee there's a bit of chicken and
egg here in that
when the largest site was granted there
was going to be some commercial and
community
use that made it sustainable and now
there isn't but we can't go back
is that anything like a reasonable
assessment
that is yeah i can't disagree with that
that's all the pathways is a very
balanced decision
okay thanks right all right actually
have council advice who wants to come
back
well yeah i think we are we never really
did have any
other side of the coin i mean i've got
at least
two large parishes
that had shops that weren't viable
changed hands numerous times
and then clothes because they just
simply
were not viable and there was no other
shop they were
in both cases the only shops in in the
village
one is a village at least as large as
north ambridge
um and you know
if you ask the the residents that would
you like a shop well of course they're
going to say yes of course we want a
shop
but somebody's got to run it and run a
viable business and
village shops are notoriously
unprofitable
um so and there's nothing worse than
building a shop and having it
empty so you know yes it would be nice
to have a shop but i i have grave doubts
over
whether it would be viable um
when so many people drive and there are
car parker and there are supermarkets
you know within driving distance
because the philly shops just can't
compete on price at the end of the day
it's it's regrettable that those
unafraid are the facts of life
so um but the question i wanted to ask
and it's one that i'm now going to be
asking
every single meeting is will each
property
have an electric vehicle charging point
if not why not if not
they should and my view is that every
single
new dwelling bill in this district
should have one from
this point forward so every time we get
an application
for a domestic dwelling i will be asking
for conditions
requiring an electric vehicle charging
point
because we are not far away chairman
from the end of internal combustion
car production so although not many
people have them now
but it's rapidly increasing and
domestic charging facilities are going
to be essential
so if it's possible to put that
condition in i would like to see it
okay um mr taylor mr lee anybody
let's go ahead so i believe that
conditioner 11 addresses that issue
it states furthermore a fast charging
point shall be provided
adjacent to at least one parking space
for each and everyone
that's part of a large condition
designed
before parking matters
thank you chairman that escaped my
notice and that's a very good condition
and one i'd like to see on every other
application
thank you very much but if you'll excuse
me ladies i have got councillor
morley and he hasn't had a first go so
i'm going to hold him back and let him
go councilman please
thank you um just inquiring really about
the presence of um the sulfate in the
water
can somebody explain to me how that's
been remedied
and actually what is it
[Music]
just interested to know uh what it does
and how it was rendered really says the
presence of water-soluble sulfate
which can significantly attack buried
concrete
remedied strategies that should be
identical and approved
to be honest
[Music]
but the presumption that the marketing
has been done for a large
commercial unit of 10 000 square foot
and then nobody's taken it so that there
isn't any
commercial demand i i actually don't
think that that's the case i think the
problem is that it was marketed as one
unit
i think that had it been designed a
smaller design
of several units of you know up to a
thousand square foot i think there would
have been demand there
the issue the problem is is that
you know they've been trying to sell a
site that is
you know half the size of a supermarket
in a village location
so i would like to have seen the
developers come back
with a smaller amount of commercial
space divided into smaller units
things like dentists veterinary surgeons
small shop you know things that a
village needs
um so i'm slightly disappointed by this
um yeah i was just reading through and
um under 5.2.3
it says that um there were no community
uses but if they didn't
that were required if they didn't
consult with the community how can they
possibly know whether it would have been
taken up or not by the community
so that's an issue and likewise as my
fellow ward member said with the
units um it did say here somewhere and i
can't find it now
um that um they had inquiries that were
interested
but they didn't really hear from them
again and i said i don't know
perhaps that something could inform me i
would imagine they showed interest
before clothed and obviously it's all
die to death
and it doesn't say that things were
followed up you know and i i do think
this is premature
and i think if anything this should be
deferred
and i'd like to impress that we at least
defer it until a proper public
consultation has been taken out with the
local residents after all
it was granted on the the big
application was granted my premise that
there would be
a commercial area providing and who's
very excited about getting a shop
um or shops plural and
you know i i think it's not practical to
use the trainers the other wall members
have said to go to
woodland fairies to get a pint of milk
or something and i'd like to see
north families become a prosperous rural
very so i think that's
part of it maybe some of the residents
would prefer to have housing but i think
we have a duty to try and
improve these areas and i don't think a
sufficient public consultation has been
carried out it's not just about
commercial consultations
we have to think of our residents so i
mindful football proposal that we defer
it
or refuse it pending a proper public
consultation where the residents
are consulted about what they want and
what they need
because it was granted in the first
application it was part of the
application that we we allowed it
i'm not entirely sure if the deferral
would be the right
i understand what you're saying but i
suspect it would be a refusal
on those grounds of looking at mr lee
chairman my advice would be fairly
difficult because if you deferred it and
you consulted and they
came back to say they wanted lots of
different things you wouldn't really be
able to do anything with that
information
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
because we don't believe that a a public
consultation has been carried out as
this was part of the original
application and um we'd like a
non-covered
um and smaller unit conversation and a
public consultation to the
residents who lived there i don't know
if i'll get any supporters
let's see for that i'll second that okay
one council fill even got in first i
mean i suspect there's a bit more
chicken and egg here as well in that if
the houses were there people might
know what they wanted yeah but how do
you do that counselor did you have cover
but i think we're going about this the
wrong way because as i said earlier
if you have a public consultation and
you say to the people that live there
what would you like of course they'd
like to shop and they'd like a dentist
and they like the doctors and they like
the vets and they like
um you know hairdressers and uh you know
just about everything else but that's
just that they won't be viable
i think that the way to look at it and
councillor fleming was
was perhaps correct in saying it hasn't
been marketed commercially
for smaller units and that is that is
more to the point
of seeing whether smaller units are
economically viable and you just you
would assess that by the fact that
whether there would be any papers for
them
um so i would be happier to see to see
that route
rather than go to the to the residence
and say what would you like because
you'll have a great long shopping list
none of which will be viable and we'll
have a row of empty
uh empty buildings but um
[Music]
i have sympathy with them but i think we
have to be realistic on this
[Music]
council uh
thank you chairman uh i would just like
to back up with cancer durham said
in terms of the situation village shops
are really nice but they're not
sustainable
and we've got to look at how we use the
site and utilize the site
uh the previous application did not put
forward
ten units it looked forward one unit
that one unit is not viable
so therefore we have to look at what's
on the table now and
uh yeah i think we're we're sort of the
losing sight of the application
that's in front of us yeah
well counselor right you're absolutely
entitled to stick with your proposal
and i would like to put forward a
proposal this application
is refused as i don't think he was
effectively marketed due to coping 19
it's caused issues i don't think that
the explosion by developers to actually
construct buildings has been explored
i also think it's against all the
relevant nppa policies
of trying communities sustainability and
rural
employment which are all important and
they're the reasons i give
for refusing the application
you know every other one is refused on
subverting abilities there's no shop and
there is
not a single shop or business
effectively in that area
thank you councillor fleming are you
still alright seconding that
i don't think it's changed substantially
but i just want to check yes
in the middle of nowhere had they
marketed it as several small units
i'm sure that there would have been
demand there for some sort of service
whether it was dentists
vets doctors hairdresser beautician
whatever that would have so people would
have come forward definitely if you've
had small units
of five six hundred square feet it's the
fact that they have marketed
one large lump of a building that is
half the size
of a supermarket there were never going
to be any takers
[Music]
okay right yeah that i might come back
to supplementary
you know it it would be a problem it was
a mix of residential and commercial but
i think to throw the commercial out with
the
barcode and just say no no it's not
viable i think it's bizarre because the
unit at huntington's they've got smaller
units and they are always
full they're never empty for very long
they get rented out very quickly there's
lots of diverse businesses there in
stone areas
okay right actually
some sections um but i think that goes
back to the point that this is that's
application's only been an outline stage
you know
um you know if you were looking
personally you know i was looking to
start a hairdresser before
thank you well okay members we've got a
proposal on the table it's newly
seconded
um i think it's been clear enough
certainly for me
so could we have uh vote please
showing hands can we have those in faith
can you make it really really clear
right one
two three okay that's three in favor of
the proposal which is to refuse those
against the proposal to refuse
one two three four okay well
we've said it next at all so um
for completeness we actually have to put
the recommendation because you can't
just not agree um
so i'm going to put the officer's
recommendation is there a second version
on the floor for that please councillor
darren thank you very much
so those in favor of the officer's
recommendation to approve
please show one two three four those
against
one two three okay
approve according to the recommendation
and report thank you
sometimes i do sometimes i appreciate it
[Music]
okay moving on we're now looking at
land north of orchard way like playing
with the bishops
and the presenting officer is miss so
clue anywhere near right
um we do have two public speakers
are we going to bring them in so they
see the presentation or are they going
to watch the presentation and then come
in
they're watching the presentation in
minority rooms that's fine
okay when you're ready
thank you chairman um
um so the application site is located
to the essentially
and does not fall within any device in
the boundary
the site is finally an open land used
for grazing of forces and
graphically the area slopes to the west
as you can see on this plan planning
permission
is short for the invention of five or
five bedroom dwelling
as stone on the side plant the building
will be split into
two this one and this buildings
which will be connected with the glazed
link here the proposal includes the
ring planting of an altered and the
introduction of
an open meadow and a wildlife
pond the elevations
show that the development would utilize
the chains and ground levels as you can
see
on this this one so one of the proposed
dwelling
is to be two-story uh one views from my
blame
this would appear as single story this
is the
more plain view so
these are the rest of the elevations
the floor plan the ground floor now
and actually it's the upper floor plan
and the lower ground
floor plan and these are some of the
photographs of the site the views
towards the north
and the south and what's the existing
access to the site
and also some views from within the site
and towards its boundary
so the proposed development has been
assessed against the
development plan and all with regulatory
planning considerations
taking into account the council's
previous decision within the vicinity of
the site
i'm talking about the north of fernbrook
hall
and in this instance it is considered
that the principle of the provision of
one dwelling in this location
is acceptable it is considered that once
the first development is not located
within
a defined settlement boundary it is an
allocation that the county
has previously found development
acceptable furthermore
prior appropriate weight should be given
to
the scheme in relation to their
biodiversity features
and landscaping proposed which are
conceited to weigh
obviously in favor of police development
in environmental terms
and no objection is raised in relation
to the impact of development
on the design residential amenity
or parking and for that reason officers
recommend approval of the application
subjective conditions stated on painters
69 to
72 of the agenda thank you thank you
right we do have these two public
speakers and we're just waiting for them
to arrive
each
okay
thank you yes we have mr waldrop who's
the parish council representative
first um and then
in short okay mr wardrop you have
two minutes precisely from when you
begin to speak please
make yourself comfortable use the
microphone and i'm afraid i will stop
you even if it's mid-sentence
two minutes i've been here before
thank you the parish council remains of
the view that this application should be
refused
to get the weight has been given to the
fact that committee approves an
application for a thunderbolt all near
this site
committee will recall their approvals
contributed a very strong advice given
to them by their officers
parish council accepts the committee's
entitlement to reject obviously advice
but that decision was taken on the basis
of the specific aspects of that case
officers should be consistent if
officers recommended strongly
refurbished should not be approved they
should not be recommending approval of
this one
their reasoning should not have changed
by a decision by councillors in a
specific instance
applications of little hill farm and the
old victory both near
the center of the village were refused
by the committee albeit the former was
approved
both refusals were partly on grounds of
sustainability and in the case of the
former
european inspector knowledge of sa his
the ldp other developments in the land
were on brownfield sites or where there
were existing buildings to be replaced
in the phonebook case councillors noted
that the proposed development replaced
an existing building
this does not apply in this case this
application is the development of an
open field which has had no building
structures on
there are views from the land across the
higher points in the village
developing it will detract from the
character of the area
our one eight of the officers report
quotes are 78 to the ndpf
the planning policies should identify
options and abilities to grow and fire
on one house in this allocation will not
delay
the site is outside and development
boundary and is not in a sustainable
location
we believe it is conflict of two
policies of the recently made
neighborhood plan
and we believe this application should
be refused
okay reset the clock
and let's this is karen barbell who is
the agent
against fargo i know you know the rules
but um
please make sure comfortable please use
the microphone and it's two minutes from
when you begin to speak connected
my name
a cable on this is the application is
for a new house created with us
within a significantly enhanced i o
diverse habitat
the approach is aimed at giving an
opportunity to reinstate or sort of in
the village
the proposed development seeks to
provide a home in a substantially
improved habitat
a primary concern was to design a house
that could contribute positively to the
local character
by demonstrating an understanding of the
special landscape setting
character materials holes and pallets of
the village
while still respecting the rural setting
of moblane itself
the design principles are based on
sensitive site analysis combined with
sustainable aspirations
of the applicants resulting in
development that sits sympathetically
within the landscape
detailed explanations are given and
illustrated in the supporting
application documents
the application has attracted
considerable local support
the inclusion of a scientifically
measured biodiversity net value
calculation
on the proposals before you demonstrate
a net gain of 88
in habitat species and 19.25
gain in hedgerow units which can be
achieved
this specific design proposal provides a
way for molten district council to
demonstrate an
integrated approach to new development
without detriment to the character and
appearance of the area we would be
pleased if you would support this
application
in line with your officer's
recommendation
thank you members and just before we do
get started remember i just want to say
that the officers
aren't changing their minds but they are
and i'll say
so the officers have to the officers are
obliged to take previous decisions into
account because they are material
planning considerations and therefore
just because they're recommended to
refuse the first one
doesn't mean they're going to recommend
to refuse the second one because of the
decision
okay are there any i'll just ask if
there are any questions of fact like how
i use it how far is it from here
otherwise we'll go straight into the
debate so we'd like to go first
[Music]
okay right well for completeness i'm
going to put it even though i think i
know which way this is i'm going to put
the officer's recommendation to approve
uh could i have a secondary yes
practically everybody um
councilman i'd like to comment of course
council
thank you thank you um it is in my world
as you're aware
this is a difficult situation and i
totally accept
what the parish council has said
however that a couple of their points in
that
uh whereas this application doesn't meet
the recognized housing need
i think we have to put it into context
of where this application is it's on no
plane and
it's predominantly extremely large
dwellings um i think it's probably one
of the wealthiest uh
raids in in the country uh so perhaps
anything you could argue that anything
other than
a similar dwelling would look somewhat
incongruous you certainly wouldn't want
a lot of two bedroom houses on combat
and i think
uh taking on board what the the um
speaker from the parish council said
um actually circumstances as we all know
are slightly different now to when the
decision was taken
in respect to the firm report in
relation to five-year land supply et
cetera et cetera
and you should know that i actually
voted against
all but i think on this occasion
there are significant other grounds
to to actually approve this application
he's with a heavy heart because i don't
like
ignoring what the parish council has
said and it's very
um concerning that it's contravenes
their name with the plan which was very
hard fought
and went to went to referendum on the
same day as
the recent elections but i think you
know
sustainable location well you know it's
similar to all the other houses in that
area
and as we've said whether you like the
um the recall
decision that is a material
consideration
and i think that we would be in a very
difficult place
if we if we turn this down on the back
of
that decision that some members made
from before
i've said my piece thank you thank you
i've got council of civil
a bit quickly thank you
i just wanted to check in terms of the
conditions is the orchard
and all the habitat and things like that
is that part of the conditions
and does if if the orchard dies in five
years times
what what is the situation in terms of
that so
yeah is that something that we condition
is that something that
we can put a tpo on it immediately
um to ensure that those trees are kept
in pure
perpetuity
i will give you the number
[Music]
yeah so it's um conditions
11 which helps out with engagement
enhancement enhancement measures
in accordance with the holosphere
appraisal that was certainly seen
in the 5 and condition 12 which relates
to the biodiversity enhancement strategy
and also there is a competition um
about the protection of the existing
trees
uh along the western boundary
which is condition 15. okay so
with the new trees can
is that
although we're not explicitly talking
about the trees we are talking about the
biodiversity
of quality benefits and they actually go
hand in hand so um
right well we do have the proposal to
agree the officer's recommendation on
the table could i have a show of hands
for those in favor please
i'm saying but we have one two three
four
five six seven well i thought i mean
nobody again so all right close against
that's
okay okay so everyone um that
application is agreed and approved in
line with the officer's
report and recommendation thank you
right so i'm going to ask
miss fardel and mr water
please to travel out that way
while we get ready for item seven
which is advanced adjacent to mosclin's
farm which is pearly
there was a members update circulated
prior to the meetings everyone
found that got that read it thank you
um
the presenting officer is miss tassa
thank you again um public speaking we
have some speaking for the applicant
and so we're going to have the
presentation and then um
please but presentation first i guess
so the application side
is located outside in a development
boundary
in a rural setting to the north west of
the village of fairly
muslin's farm is located in the
southwest
side of terms of road and
the barn itself relates to a two-story
timber
boarded bar previously used for
agricultural purposes
the application is partially
retrospective and sex
regularize the existing works cards out
to the bar
and gain permission to the conversion of
the building to a dwelling house
and some other external changes have not
yet been carried out
the following plans show the existing
and plants and elevations and the
proposed
plants and elevations
this is the roof plan which is the same
for the existing
and proportioned this is the street
scene
this is the building this is the font we
converted
this is a cyclist set which is closely
located within
the rear garden or there
and this is the landscaping fan
and some pictures this is the building
it is noted that a similar application
for a personally retrospective
application to convert the bar into a
dwelling house
was refused on 4th of may 2021
due to the impact of the development on
the character of the area
it's for sustainability credentials as
well as the absence of assigned legal
agreement
to secure necessary funding for rounds
the conversion of the bond to a dwelling
house was also previously found
unacceptable
by the northwestern planning committee
under the terms of application
20 slash 00310 slash ful
the application seeks to regulate to
regularize part of the originally
implemented prior approval scheme which
has not been completed within the time
period or in accordance with the first
class
as such the prior refuel is no longer
extend
the development is now unauthorized and
does not benefit from a fallback
position
it should be noted that the criteria for
the determination of a prior approval
application
is under committed development
legislation and as a result the
development
was not assessed against the local plan
policies
or other material funding considerations
under this application
it is considered that the development
fails to comply with the development
plan
and the ndpf specifically the
development is considered
unacceptable due to its food
sustainability conditions
and unacceptable appearance which
represents how hard to account recites
also the development due to the absence
of assigned legal agreement to secure
necessary financial contribution towards
rams
uh will potentially have an impact to
nato conservation sites
consideration has been given to the
planning history of the site
and the approval of the adjoining site
which was not considered to outweigh the
conflict
with the development plan for that
reason officers recommend refusal of
this application
for the reasons stated on page 97
or 95 sorry of the agenda
thank you very much uh right well
this is good okay uh
right um you will have two minutes to
speak please use your microphone i'm
just going to hit the clock up
the clock will start as you begin to
speak
you've got precisely two minutes and i'm
afraid i will stop you in the middle of
the sentence if it happened
that's right thank you
good evening and thank you for the
opportunity to speak we seek planning
permission to convert the second half of
existing rounds wedding
this committee approved the first half
of the barn into a single dwelling
approved on the basis that issues
providing community space have been
addressed and that the council lacked a
five-year housing land supply
our application is for dwelling within a
sustainable location
involving five successful appeals
between 2016 and 2019
for residential development along
chancellor growth per day
the sustainability of the site was
acknowledged by this committee resulting
in approval of our attached
neighbouring farmer the development of
the second half of the barn
will not cause harm to the local panzco
character with many local residents
confirming their support
the intent to restore the barn in a
sympathetic way consistent with the work
undertaken to the first half of the barn
all of pearl's local emulating
communities are accessible on foot
via the private all-weather footpath
which the council accepted in may
this year there is also the t1 and d2
bus routes
heading and bus company have confirmed
they service this job
which is only 427 27 meters
from the site our application now meets
one of the campus requirements
parking spaces volume sizes and the
provisional
storage we have now paid the additional
sum of 1.72
towards the essex rams mitigation the
fee having increased
during the course of our earlier
application the development includes the
appearance
of a formerly derived building forming a
positive addition to pearly village
that enhances the areas of humans and
character
we respectfully ask the community
support thank you
and actually asked answered my questions
which would have
sorted the rounds out and so that's one
good thing are there any
questions how far
oh right let's go straight to the debate
and i saw council white
buses um i just
was curious as to whether the use of the
bicycle hadn't been
fitted thank you
i mean um the the road
the central road is the only road that
the
um property has access to so this is the
only way that
someone had an advantage invite
along so it does as i said it does not
benefit from
a footpath or anything i mean cyclists
do go through roads and they can also
utilize their
proposed and formalized football but
again
this is yeah this is thank you the point
i was making sure is that
uh all the amenities of the village are
accessible
thank you okay right
thank you councilwoman and i was at the
planning committee when we refused
the first part of the planning
commission because the um
community development had got over time
but
um they the gardens didn't meet the
design standards there were lots of
issues
and since then they put in the footpath
they've made the gardens bigger
these bombs were already part converted
anyway so for me there's going to be no
change to the
rural area because they're already there
and they're already half converted
and um we approved the other half at
northwest planning the other month um so
i think it's ridiculous to
um refuse this half and i think that by
the way
that we approve this half the
application it's sustainable every
appeal the presidential has been
um won at um early full residential
i mean funny inspectors come up with the
fact that he believes it's sustainable
until it
depends if
mr louie
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so yeah sorry i'll i'll get you involved
we need to make sure we're talking about
the right proposal
um so could you
would you care to tighten up your
reasons given that that really is
because the site has been found to be um
sustainable at appeal
or the village in that area has been
found to be sustainable at appeal
and we approved the the original refusal
was overcome
by the provisional footpath and extra
car parking spaces
and we recently at northwest planning
approved the other half of the barn
and at that time we found it sustainable
and we found there was no harm to the um
rural scene so for that reason i find it
sustainable and it should be approved to
meet with the
people okay council keys is still well
council keys right now i've actually got
three more people to speak with
councillor
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
is the fact that it's retrospective and
i think you know
if members do decide to um
to agree this is definitely not
for the reason that half of it is there
and has been done effectively
illegally you know honestly
as i said under normal circumstances
retrospective
flanker puts out a red flag for me
um because it's far too easy to build
things
without permission and then come back
come to us and say well it's hard
but as i said they're saying i i
actually don't have a
significant issue with this except for
the faculty is retrospective
um yeah um okay
yeah i mean clients are great the fact
that it's partly there
and it's retrospective is um
it's just i can't find it in here but i
had it come up with one of my in my
board
what are the building times on this
because being a farmer
partly farmer i suppose um i know
they're doing it themselves and
this is not belleway homes or permission
homes you know if he can't
he gets up in the morning as we all know
the weather's not
particularly well judged on phones and
bits and pieces
could we alter the time restrictions on
it i can't see what they are now but
the only person next doors is someone
that owns part of it which is part of
the family so he's not going to be out
there knowing that i'm tired at two in
the morning but i just don't want it it
came up in one of my
my awards where he said he's doing
himself
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
but i i would um appreciate that it is a
site that's fairly young that we don't
have the normal working hours
um you know nine to four or whatever
yeah especially
[ __ ] two things firstly generally i
would like to just because
the neighbors could be family we
shouldn't trade into council matter
plans we should be run to decide to be
sold by the law certainly as we said
in that case if we wouldn't impose
restriction on hours on construction
because
[Music]
about this the work was started under a
cooper application
i understand it wasn't just that they
just suddenly decided to start work i
understand yeah
um yes another one was trying to do
anything underhanded it
started
[Music]
thank you jeff i might be
misunderstanding
something here and it has already been
stated that
we've provided permission for the first
half i just don't understand
when that perhaps mr lee can help me
here why
[Music]
the council um the views
[Music]
um
or the cannon white human service
decision on this exact building
is mostly different way into the joining
building but as i said it comes down to
the plan
like your personal job
dedicated to the officers and
[Music]
on the ground basically sustainability
but did you
okay one two three four
five six um
generally decides to learn that there
are none so
items meeting members and officers thank
you
thank you for their contributions